Completa el cuadrado en la ecuación general cuadrática ax cuadrada más bx más "c" igual a 0.
Y bueno ni te imaginas a dónde vamos a llegar.
Lo primero que voy a hacer es, es que a mí no me gusta tener el término a x cuadrada,
prefiero tener solamente a "x"  cuadrada y así es mucho más fácil
trabajarlo a mi parecer, por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es quitar esta "a" que está multiplicando "x" cuadrada,
dividiendo todo entre "a", todo entre "a", todo entre "a",todo entre "a"
y bueno "a" entre "a" se van y me queda simple y sencillamente "x" cuadrada
esto es 1 por "x" cuadrada o sea "x" cuadrada más "b" entre "a" por "x" más "c" entre
"a", y lo voy a poner un poco más espaciado, por que lo que quiero es completar el binomio al cuadrado perfecto,
más "c" entre "a", y después tengo que esto es igual a 0 entre "a" pero 0 entre lo que sea es 0 muy bien.
Una expresión que me parece mucho más amigable, por que con esta expresión voy a completar el binomio cuadrado perfecto y recuerda que para completar
el binomio cuadrado perfecto, me fijo siempre en el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x" que en este caso es "b" entre "a".
Y bueno esto es lo mismo que 2 por "b" entre 2a
él 2 con el 2 se cancela y me quedaría "b" entre "a", y esto lo pongo así por que recuerda que al coeficiente que está al
lado de la "x" siempre hay que dividirlo entre 2,
para encontrar así mi segundo término. En este caso mi segundo término es "b" entre 2a
y si yo pongo el cuadrado de "b" entre 2a pues es "b" entre 2a
elevado todo al cuadrado para no confundirnos.
Y bueno yo estoy agregando aquí "b" entre 2a elevado al cuadrado, de la nada, si lo estoy agregando de la nada,
recuerda que también lo tengo que quitar de la nada, por lo tanto voy a
restarle "b" entre 2a al cuadrado. Si lo sumo y lo resto, al final es 0 y entonces realmente es como si no estuviera haciendo nada.
Y bueno lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que estos 3 primeros
términos es un trinomio al cuadrado perfecto, por que tengo el cuadrado del primero más 2 veces el primero por el segundo, más el
cuadrado del segundo y yo sé que tal vez visto de una forma general es un poco confuso y no quiero que te confundas con tantas
"a", "b", "c" etcétera. Y bueno para que sea mucho más fácil voy a escribir aquí la fórmula del binomio al cuadrado perfecto pero, ten cuidado
no vayas a mezclar estas "m" y "n" con "a", "b" y"c".
"m" más "n" elevado al cuadrado es lo mismo que "m" cuadrada más 2 veces el primero por el segundo 2 "m" y "n",
más "n" cuadrado que es justo lo que tenemos aquí. Si te das cuenta
tenemos un trinomio cuadrado perfecto y por lo tanto ya sé, que en ese segundo término, el segundo término se "b" entre 2a
y entonces lo puedo escribir de la forma "m" más "n"
elevado al cuadrado. Fíjate bien aquí tengo 2 veces el primero por el segundo y 2 cuadrados, el cuadrado de
"x" y el cuadrado de "b" entre 2a por lo tanto esto de aquí lo puedo escribir de la siguiente manera.
Como todo esto de rojo es un trinomio cuadrado perfecto, lo voy a factorizar y ¿En que lo voy a factorizar?
En "x" más "b" entre 2a al cuadrado.
Date cuenta que esto es lo mismo que lo que está de rojo aquí arriba, y después tengo que hacer esta operación
de aquí pero, lo primero que voy a hacer es elevar el "b" entre 2a al cuadrado, entonces me queda menos
y me quedaría "b" cuadrada.
Aquí hay que poner el cuadrado de ambos, el cuadrado del de arriba y el cuadrado del de abajo entonces me va a quedar "b" cuadrada
entre 2a al cuadrado que es 4a cuadrada y a esto le tengo que sumar "c" entre "a".
Y sería muy bueno ya sacar de una vez el factor común pero, primero lo voy a poner como "c" entre "a" para que no te confundas,
y ahorita voy a sacar el denominador común para poder sumar estas 2 expresiones que tengo aquí.
Ahora date cuenta que lo que le falta a la "a"
para ser 4a cuadrada es multiplicar por 4a por lo tanto voy a multiplicar por 4a tanto arriba como abajo.
Esta expresión me va a quedar 4ac entre 4a cuadrada.
Lo que me va a dar un denominador común y entonces estos 2 sumandos se van a poder reducir,
se van a poder reducir por que tengo una suma de quebrados y esto va a ser igual a 0.
Entonces déjenme escribirlo aquí abajo, me queda "x" más "b" entre 2a
todo esto elevado al cuadrado, y después tengo como denominador común 4a cuadrada por lo tanto ya puedo sumar estas 2 expresiones
y arriba me quedaría 4ac positivo y - "b" cuadrada, entonces lo voy a poner aquí
-b cuadrada más 4ac y todo esto está dividido entre 4a cuadrada y esto es igual a 0,
bueno pero, la idea tras la que voy es despejar a "x" o al menos dejar el término "x" -"b" entre 2a al cuadrado,
lo más solo que se pueda de algún lado de la ecuación,
por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es pasar todo este término del otro lado, por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es
cambiarle de signo a los términos que están
arriba de este quebrado pero, déjame hacerlo con otro color. Voy a tomar el color azul y bueno, entonces le voy a cambiar el signo
a los sumandos que están aquí arriba, para que se cancelen y entonces los pueda pasar del otro lado. Me va a quedar "b" cuadrada
-4ac  entre 4a cuadrada
y del otro lado tengo que hacer lo mismo, si estoy sumando de un lado también lo tengo que hacer del otro lado
para que la igualdad se mantenga entonces, ahora sí ¿Qué me va a quedar de sumar esto y sumar esto del otro lado?
Bueno yo tengo que esto de amarillo y esto de azul, se va a cancelar por que - "b" cuadrada más "b" cuadrada se van,
- 4ac más 4ac se van y simple y sencillamente me quedaría que todo esto se va.
Entonces me queda del lado izquierdo de la ecuación "x" más "b" entre 2a todo esto elevado al cuadrado.
Esto ya se fue y del lado derecho de mi ecuación a quién me va a quedar,
esto va a ser igual a "b" cuadrada  -, espera espera mejor, déjame ponerlo con color azul y así no nos vamos a confundir.
Mientras que del lado derecho me va a quedar "b" cuadrada -4ac
entre 4a cuadrada y bueno si lo que queremos resolver es para "x"
entonces lo que voy a hacer es sacar raíz cuadrada de ambos lados de la ecuación y ¿Qué me va a quedar?
Recuerda que tras lo que voy es despejar a "x" por lo tanto voy a sacar raíz cuadrada de ambos lados de mi ecuación,
y recuerda que cuando yo saco raíz cuadrada,
la raíz cuadrada toma 2 raíces tanto una raíz positiva, como una raíz negativa, por lo tanto cuando yo aplico la raíz cuadrada
me va a quedar más menos, la raíz cuadrada de a lo que se le aplique, entonces voy a poner aquí mi raíz cuadrada
y voy a poner del otro lado mi raíz cuadrada.
Aquí no le voy a poner más menos, aquí sí le voy a poner más menos por la siguiente razón que les voy a explicar.
Si yo le pusiera más menos a ambos lados de la ecuación,
entonces pasaría lo siguiente, me estaría tomando más
posibilidades de las que debería, es decir al final cuando yo pase el más menos del otro lado, va a pasar como menos más y
cuando multiplique el más menos, al más al final, me va a dar un signo positivo,
y un signo negativo por lo tanto para ahorrarnos todos estos tiques solo le ponemos más menos del lado derecho de la ecuación
y bueno, la raíz con el cuadrado son operaciones inversas por lo tanto, se cancelan y del lado derecho solamente me queda
"x" más "b" entre 2a más "b" entre 2a ,
aquí desaparece la raíz cuadrada y el cuadrado, y del otro lado me queda más menos la raíz cuadrada de todo esto que está aquí.
Sin embargo quiero que veas que cuando yo saco la raíz cuadrada
de una fracción, esto es lo mismo que sacar la raíz cuadrada del
denominador y a su vez sacar la raíz cuadrada del numerador, es decir que cuando tenemos la raíz cuadrada de una fracción
podemos separar la raíz, y lo genial de todo esto es que poco a poco vamos moldeando la fórmula general de ecuaciones de segundo grado
pero bueno, aquí arriba en el numerador
tenemos una
resta y recuerda que cuando yo tengo una resta o una diferencia no puedo sacar la raíz cuadrada de cada uno de los términos, por
lo tanto voy a poner arriba
la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada - 4ac y fíjate que puse aquí más menos para no pelearme con los signos al hacer la
fracción, la verdad no importa por que siempre tenemos una raíz positiva y una raíz negativa, solamente 2 posibilidades
obtener un número negativo o tener un número positivo.
Y bueno esto entre 2a la raíz cuadrada de 4a cuadrada es 2a y ahora a
continuación lo que voy a hacer es restarle a ambos lados de la ecuación
- b entre 2a y "b" entre 2a - "b" entre 2a se va, y del lado izquierdo ya por fin me queda solamente
"x". Del lado derecho me queda -"b" entre 2a más menos la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada -4ac,
todo esto también dividido entre 2a estos dos quebrados ya tienen un denominador
común y el denominador común es 2a por lo tanto me queda - b más menos la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada -4ac
entre 2a, y si te das cuenta aquí tenemos 2 raíces una positiva y una negativa, si suponemos que la raíz cuadrada existe,
entonces me voy a tomar la raíz positiva y después no voy a tomar la raíz negativa, y esto me va a dar dos soluciones.
Cosa que es congruente con todo lo que hemos visto hasta ahorita.
Y si te das cuenta esta fórmula que tengo aquí es la fórmula que has aprendido varias veces.
Partimos de una ecuación ax cuadrada más bx más "c" igual a 0, a ésta se le conoce como la ecuación general de segundo grado
y llegamos a la solución - b más menos la raíz cuadrada de "b" cuadrada - 4ac
entre 2a ¡Hasta parece poema! Y toda esta solución es una solución muy
importante, pues a esta solución se le conoce como la fórmula
cuadrática, o en su dado caso como la solución general de las ecuaciones de segundo grado, y esta es una de las fórmulas más
importantes y que más salen en todo el mundo de las matemáticas y si te das cuenta la obtuvimos simple y sencillamente
completando el cuadrado, y aunque no soy muy fanático de que se memoricen  las cosas,
creo que te podría ser muy útil en la vida si lo haces.